[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter le
film Dupont la joie qui est un film
français réalisé par Yves Boisset en
1974 avec Jean Carmet notamment c'est un
film qui est assez dur puisqu'il
s'inspire de fait réel notamment de la
vague de meurtre raciste qui a eu lieu
en France à la fin des années 70 alors
pour vous raconter un peu l'histoire du
film donc c'est l'histoire de plusieurs
couples de Français moyen qui passe
leurs vacances à chaque fois dans un
camping du sud de la France là cette
année-là il se retrouve tous ensemble et
il va y avoir un drame c'est à dire que
la l'une des filles du couple va être
retrouvée morte à proximité du camping
et à partir de là il va y avoir des
accusations qui vont être faites à
l'encontre de d'ouvriers étrangers ce
qui était sur un chantier à proximité du
camping
et de là va partir une il va y avoir une
vague de voyage de violence envers ses
ouvriers étrangers
[Musique]
alors c'est un film que j'ai choisi
parce que je trouve que il s'inspire
bien donc de ses faits qui ont eu lieu à
la fin des années 70
je trouve que Jean Carmet incarne un
personnage qui est vraiment odieux alors
je vous dis pas pourquoi vous verrez en
regardant le film et justement à partir
de ça
j'encarmé a eu beaucoup de mal par la
suite à la suite de ce film il a eu
beaucoup de mal de trouver d'autres
rôles au cinéma pendant quelques temps
parce que cette image de personne nage
odieux lui a collé à la peau pendant de
nombreuses années
c'est un film qui a fait polémique lors
de sa sortie en salle puisqu'il y a des
scènes qui sont très choquantes
notamment la scène du meurtre et puis du
viol de la jeune fille et voilà donc je
vous conseille quand même d'aller le
voir même si certaines scènes peuvent
choquer
[Musique]